you have two fractions 1 4 and 5 6 and
you want to rewrite them so they have
the same denominator
and have whole number numerators
what numbers could you use for the
denominator
so here's our fractions 1 4 and 5 6 and
we want to rewrite these fractions to
have new denominators
so we currently have a 4 and a 6 as our
denominator and can we just put any new
thing like maybe 5 could we say let's
change them both to have 5 as the
denominator
the answer is no we have to pick a
multiple of 4 and 6 a multiple some
number that we can multiply 4
and get this number as an answer
so for example
for four
some multiples of four
would be four times one is four
four times two is eight
four times three is twelve and so on
those are multiples of 4.
and let's just pause here and look at
why we have to pick a multiple of 4
and 6. well we can't just pick any
number but we have to pick a multiple of
our denominators
so the fraction we were just talking
about was one-fourth we could look at
either one but let's look at one-fourth
here we have
a picture showing fourths
and to show one-fourth we shade one of
these four equal sized pieces
well maybe i want to change this and i
want to say i want two i want two as my
numerator
so to have a numerator of two
i'm gonna need to split this fourth up
here into two pieces
now i have two shaded pieces
so can i say this is two one
two out of one two three four five
pieces it's not two-fifths because these
are not equal-sized pieces so if i split
this fourth right here in half i need to
split all of them in half and what i'm
doing
is doubling
the amount of pieces
so now this is two pieces this is two
and this is two because we need equal
size pieces
so now this is one two pieces out of one
two three four 5 6 7 8 equal size pieces
so 2 8.
and you can see 8 is a multiple of 4
because we multiplied by 2 and that's
what we did we multiplied each of our
pieces by 2.
and we also multiplied our numerator by
two because that was also doubled the
amount of shaded pieces doubled when the
entire amount of pieces doubled
and we don't have to do this just with
two we could do any multiple of four for
example
we can do one more here
if we again let's shade one fourth
one of the four pieces
and maybe this time we want to split it
into
three equal sized pieces
so to have a new numerator of three and
these should be equal sized
here's a numerator of three
but it's
we can't do our denominator yet because
we don't have equal sized pieces so to
get equal sized pieces we'll need to
split each of these
fourths into three
so we are tripling
the amount of pieces
so now we have three shaded pieces out
of a total of 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12.
out of 12.
and i could have figured that out
without even counting because i knew
that we tripled this time
we multiplied
our original denominator times three we
tripled and we also multiplied our
numerator times 3.
so these are the multiples 8 12 and so
on and so those are the denominators we
can pick something that we can multiply
our denominator by so we can multiply
the entire amount of pieces
and again so this is super clear 1 4 and
2 8 and 3 12 they all represent the same
amount whether we had one fourth the
original here's two eighths three
twelfths they're all equivalent they all
represent the same amount they're just
different ways of writing the same
number
back to our original question what
denominators can we use for fourths
and for six
well we know we need to use multiples so
let's look at the multiples for four
we've already gone through some of these
the first multiple of four is four times
one which is four
second multiple of four is eight four
times two is eight so we could split our
fourths into in half and get eighths
or we could say four times three is
twelve
which we showed again where we split our
fourth see each fourth into three equal
pieces
or we could do four times four which is
sixteen
four times five is twenty
four times six is twenty four
and so on the reason i'm stopping at 24
is i've looked at my answer choices and
i can see the largest possible answer is
24. so i don't need to write any larger
multiples there are many many many more
multiples of 4
but we don't need to list them all
because the largest number we're going
to have to consider is 24.
let's do the same for six
we could leave our six alone six times
one
and keep six pieces or we could double
our six six times two would be twelve if
we doubled the pieces we would have
twelve pieces
we could say six times three which is
eighteen or six times four we could
divide each of our six into four pieces
and we'd have six times four which is 24
or 20 fourths
and so on again i'll stop at 24 since
it's the largest number we need to
consider
so down to our answer choices what
numbers could we use for the denominator
could we use eight
let's look at these lists
eight is a multiple of four
so we could definitely split fourths
into eights
but eight is not a multiple of six so we
cannot split six into eighths so
eight
will not work as a denominator for both
fractions
how about twelve
twelve we can see is a multiple of four
and we showed that we drew that already
and twelve is a multiple of six we could
split our six into two equal pieces each
and we would have twelfths
so twelve does work twelve is a
denominator a common denominator for
fourths and sixths
eighteen eighteen is here on the sixth
we could split six into eighteen because
eighteen is a multiple of six but it is
not a multiple of four
so we can rule out eighteen 18 is not a
common denominator and 24
you may remember was the last number we
wrote on both of them
so yes 24 could be
a denominator for fourths and sixths so
we could use either 12 or 24 and there's
a lot more numbers we could use two as
common denominators but from these
choices we could use 12 or 24 as a
common denominator for fourths and six
and just a note lots of times people
like to use the smallest one the least
common denominator which in this case is
and it makes a lot of sense because it's
easier to do computation with smaller
numbers but you don't absolutely have to
use the smallest one you could use
twelfths or twenty fourths or or lots of
other options but again twelfths is
probably the simplest one to work with
just because generally it's easier to
work with smaller numbers
but for this question the common
denominators we can use from these
choices for 4th and 6th are 12 and 24.